Hello I'm Esnot Gandwe and I'm from Malawi.
I'm part of a network of global change makers
from around the world who are recently here
in Cape Town to have a discussion on the issues
that effect them and their country. The 2010
question is a very good question to ask and
I feel that 2010, even though it is in South
Africa, the effect of it will ripple around
the countries, the rest of the countries in
Africa. And this is mainly because, coming
form Malawi, the world cup as itself, the
world cup, it's the world cup, so many people
from around the world will be coming here.
South Africa can not
[pause]
contain the whole world. So teams will be
training in other parts of, especially Southern
Africa. So Malawi is one of them. So we'll
have many teams coming in to train on our
fields which will bring in a lot of tourists.
Which will bring in a lot of recognition on
their country as a whole. Ans which will bring
in benefits. So even though the world cup
as itself, the cup is in South Africa, the
effect of this world cup will be felt all
over Africa.